it's great to welcome to the program
today Timothy Morton who's an ecological
philosopher at Rice University also
author of the book being ecological out
with penguin and MIT it's so great to
have you on today oh thank you so much
having me it's an honor and if I
couldn't do things like this I couldn't
think you have to sort of work with
other people to be able to do that if
you if you're me well let's do it I mean
I think maybe to start let's define some
terms a little bit I think that maybe
the term ecology and ecological is not
often understood by many there's sort of
something in there that relates to the
environment there's something in there
that relates the climate change probably
or maybe not so can we maybe start with
defining what the field is and what
we're talking about well the funny thing
is that the word ecology is like the
word economy and we sort of know what
economy means it commonly means like how
you organize your house actually that
first two syllables the Eco bit mates
house in Greek you know incoming
outgoing flows of money and whatever and
and and roughly it's it's sort of to do
how you organize your enjoyment right
you know like I'll give you fifty cents
and you give me this spy screen was a
very cheap ice cream for some reason
ecology is in a way the logic of that
it's the logic of where we live how it
how it works and the funny thing is of
course is that classical economic theory
doesn't seem to have anything to do very
much with coral or mountains or whatever
but I guess we're finding out right now
just how connected these things are but
actually by ignoring some of the things
like coral and mountains we might have
got some things a bit screwy with with
our with our economics with our way of
doing it
some examples of maybe the questions
that would be the questions that the
field considers oh well one very strong
question would be at what scales is this
thing happening right like in a funny
way ecological awareness just means
being aware that things are happening on
more than one scale at once
say for example you start your car
now that's actually you know on a planet
scale statistically meaningless if you
haven't done anything you shouldn't feel
built guilty in a way I like to say that
maybe there's a difference between
guilty and responsible then billions and
billions of those are doing something so
there's a funny paradox which is that on
one scale nothing's happening on another
scale everything is is happening and
it's the same thing you're doing the
same thing so in the in the field of you
know climate change in environmentalism
one debate that exists that I think is a
is a better one than does it exists I
think that that's not a good debate at
this point but one is personal
responsibility versus corporate
responsibility so the discussion of
plastic straws and getting a car with
slightly better gas mileage or whatever
the case may be and a counter to the
entire framing of those questions is
that this is not really about the
decisions of the individual because the
overwhelming I think it's you know 70%
of emissions come from just a hundred
companies or something like that
so that the conversation is actually
happening at the wrong scale within the
ecological framework as you say you know
there's the little action and things are
happening on multiple layers is there a
particular level of zooms so to speak
that is the predominant one in the
questions you deal with well you're
quite right to suggest I feel that the
individual scale is a little bit too
small and it also brings up questions of
good and evil like am I doing this right
you know what's the right shampoo to
choose I've got 200 shampoos in the shop
and I'm confronted with them like this
giant ice floe only it's made of shampoo
and I have to figure out which one to do
and it's quite alien you know and of
course there's a awful feeling of
powerlessness when you're thinking about
something happening a planet scale and
I'm old enough to remember those things
in the 90s where in the media sometimes
people would say things like if we just
did this one thing like save toilet
paper or jump up and down on the spot
for a while then this would happen if we
just did it for two weeks then this
other amazing thing would happen and
it's as if the onus is put on on us as
individuals and I like to distinguish
between guilty and responsible I'm doing
this interview across from
Chevron and all those companies because
they work at Rice University in in
Houston and it's quite clear who's
guilty in a way like some people knew
that dope warning was happening and that
and so forth quite a long time ago
rather like the cigarette situation on
the other hand everyone's responsible
and it doesn't mean that even that you
have to prove that you did it all you
have to prove is that you can understand
it right like if you see somebody
running in the street and they're going
to get hit by a car you're responsible
for that person and you don't have to
prove even that you didn't and even
maybe it might waste some time you know
you might be trying to prove that you
did it with a calculator and suddenly
the person got hit anyway so in a funny
way I feel like taking a lot of that
guilt of the people's shoulders and I
feel like people like me often make
ordinary people feel stupid and evil and
and that's probably why our messages and
working so great what is it that when it
comes to solving the problems that we're
dealing with you see as the biggest
impediment because it's very easy and I
think at least partially accurate to say
that there are significant corporate
interests that stand to lose a lot of
money if we actually start dealing
seriously with the problems that we're
having but that I think is only one
piece of it so are there others there's
this idea of analysis paralysis of
endlessly seeking facts without a path
forward I'll just open it what else is
preventing us from solving this the way
that we talk to each other about it is
quite inhibiting and sometimes like to
think that it's not exactly how what you
think that could start World War four or
whatever but but how you think yeah like
there are different ideas for example
about what the word believe means you
know disbelief I mean hold on really
really tight or something and never let
go or just believe means something more
like trusting you know just sort of
allowing things to be the case and so
you know in a way it's to do with what
we think all these deep things about
what does believe mean what's
responsible mean and in general how do
we act in groups you know I mean we we
own our daily lives we're members have
lots and lots of overlapping
intersecting different sizes of group
and if we're going to work with this
global warming stuff it's a 7.5 billion
group problem and and that's a big
challenge actually to imagine ourselves
as part of a group without thinking that
the group is like this glass of water in
which we just dissolve like salt or
sugar and we don't really mean anything
and we don't really exist and it's a
tremendously inhibiting to think you
know and again perhaps it's a hangover
from not not so great aspects of some
religion that's feeling like you're part
of something bigger makes you feel like
you you don't count yeah I in his book
Guns Germs and Steel Jared Diamond talks
quite a bit about the size of groups in
which humans can function in different
ways and to different degrees and it
seems that when we're talking about
ecology we we really are talking about
the planet I mean everybody is part of
it in a sense and that seems
overwhelming to some degree is this the
role is this why we have governments I
mean either I don't want to be
pessimistic and maybe you're not
pessimistic but how do we wrap our mind
around how to solve the problem of that
scope in size I have awful trouble with
with negative feelings about this so I
feel badly a lot some of my favorite
hobbies is feeling badly and I feel like
if I'm just lying there in the fetal
position you know on the floor which is
how I feel sometimes when I hear this
data there's nothing I can do about it
you know so I have to figure out how to
scrape myself off the floor and get up
and do something so one has to feel
somewhat confident in the face of the
the awfulness I think really that what
we're dealing with is obviously a again
it's a it's a problem to do with knowing
that what you do at one scale might suck
at another scale right like like very
crudely knowing that everything sort of
interconnected on the planet means that
if you're going to be nice to bunny
rabbits it means that you're not going
to be nice to bunny rabbit parasites so
part of it is this Groundhog Day
situation if you remember the film
Groundhog Day Bill Murray tries to get
it right when I keeps going through the
same day over and over
then when he realizes he could never
ever save the guy who's going to get hit
and that's a little bit like ecological
awareness there's always going to be
some flaw in your plan but that doesn't
mean you should you should not try to
carry it out and so part of it is you
know realizing that we're always gonna
feel a little bit like hypocrites and
we're each gonna wonder exactly why
we're doing what we're doing there
aren't quite enough reasons all the time
when it comes to action I mean is there
do you think in on those terms is there
when we look at you know fossil fuels
trash plastics the oceans the ozone all
of these different things
is there even something that you would
say should be the areas of focus at this
point oh well actually it's very easy
for an individual person to realize that
actually the best thing you can do as an
individual is to eat a little bit less
than meat if you're wondering what to do
right now and you're feeling overwhelmed
by all of this and the way we talk to
each other about it is so triggering in
sort of PTSD and you open the paper and
it says they know 500 to 16% 20,000
years and it's all so confusing and then
there's another lot of data dumped on
either next day you know and then you
read the editorial section and it's like
oh you're really evil you're bad you
know and so no wonder people feel put
off but actually there's something very
simple you can do while we're waiting
for people to do bigger things which is
eat a little bit less meat it's amazing
how much fossil fuel emmissions there
are in agriculture and if you want to do
something right now I I would seriously
advise I would seriously advise that as
you put a car and if you do and it's
probably quite expensive to pay it off
maybe it's better just to focus on the
food right now and not worry so much
about about the aspect that's
interesting and that's something I try
to do and and I advocate for and yet if
I recall correctly I think agricultural
emissions are something like 13% of
total emissions so we sort of are back
in this position of even if we all did
it we're dealing with maybe 1/10 of the
problem and is that maybe what gets some
people to do nothing instead I think so
yes there's a feeling of paralysis and
you know I guess one of the most
important things
in the short-term it's a relative vote
you know figure out who can represent
you who can work some things out
politically in in larger groups it's
it's probably more effective than
anything I think right now even though
some things may seem more to see
seemingly direct and sort of more
obvious or flamboyant for regular folks
I think just figuring out who's the
right person to vote for with all of
this is probably the best is probably
the best tactic right now in thinking a
little more broadly like maybe five
years ten years twenty years our
individual conversations where you try
to convince someone who simply doesn't
believe that we are affecting the
climate and our planet is that a
worthwhile conversation to have or are
those sort of vestigial remains so to
speak that will eventually go away and
we that's not really where our focus
should be arguing with people about
whether it's real course that's
interesting them well you know the funny
thing is that you know the wondering
whether it's real or not it's in a funny
way a symptom of the fact that it's real
I don't know if you've ever been in a
car accident but when you're in
something like that
some kind of traumatic situation the
thought is gosh is this really happening
and all around the world people think is
this actually for real this global
warming mass extinction thing and that's
actually a signal that it is happening
in a funny in a funny way another thing
to say about this is that that kind of
conversation where you try to convince
someone yeah probably that kind of
conversation has hoovered up as many
people as it possibly can now who want
to believe this stuff I think it's
probably more effective to have other
kinds of conversation that don't
necessarily also direct like for example
have a conversation about responsibility
you know like again maybe jellyfish did
this but because I can understand it I
can responsible through it right and
because I've got fingers that can switch
off the keyboard switches that switch
off the oil pipes I need to do this
because dolphins can't do it because
their flippers can't like keyboards so
but I mean so the the idea in thinking
pragmatically then is that although
there's nothing wrong necessarily with
trying to convince people but that has
been
going on for so long that the convince'
Balai Klee already have been a my sort
of understanding what you're saying yes
yes exactly exactly I feel like you know
I I was in the local burger place I live
in Texas and so what a burger is our
Texas burger place we're all very proud
of it and I had just seen an incredible
retired ballet dancer doing this
incredible performance of this Debussy
ballet in Paris and then the person who
served me the sources because as opposed
someone comes with a tray with the
sources at this place came to the table
to serve this I thought gosh you you are
handling yourself as gracefully as this
ballet dancer person in Paris and you
know people like me make people like you
feel stupid and evil most of the time no
wonder we haven't started fixing this
thing like I mean obviously there's
other things to blame but who can I
blame but myself if the situation isn't
isn't going so great
any situation right I don't know if
you've seen the Democratic presidential
debates that have taken place so far but
if you have I'd be curious to know what
is your assessment of the way in which
these issues are discussed whether its
climate fossil fuels energy whatever I
mean in terms of the questions that are
asked is sort of part a and in terms of
the the framing of the answers as well
gosh that's very very deep and it's very
very important because again I feel like
how you do a thing is the thing in a way
it's not an optional extra how we ask
ourselves questions about this and how
we talk about it and it seems to me that
the way it's talked about quite often is
you know perhaps some of the solutions
are right but the language is very tiny
aquatic and it's not very democratically
empowering and it's not scaled so that
you don't think like what can I do is I
mean is someone in my neighborhood right
like what can I do is someone in my
school is in a street all is in a town
of course there needs to be trans States
international action on all of this
stuff and yet and at the same time I
think the way we talk about it makes it
seem like this very scary alien thing
and it is scary but it better not be
alien because if it's alien and it's
just
something that happens like fate or
destiny or nature or whatever the old
word nature that I do that things just
should have happened without your will
you know and this is something that we
have to input our will into so the way
we talk about it is a little bit
stifling myself that's a very good
question
what would be an example of a question
that you would like to hear from
moderators posed to the candidates that
would maybe be more encompassing or
framed in a better way hmm how do you
think
neighborhoods and local communities can
organize to affect ecological political
change would be my number one question
just to get people in the mindset of
thinking this is a thing we can do you
know like we all live in a neighborhood
and in a funny way the neighborhood is
sort of a very good unit of political
change you know it's not individuals
it's a group but it's small enough and
it's connected enough to your actual
physical location and what who you are
and who you know that it's it's it's got
this reality to it that's interesting I
mean just I'm imagining it being asked
and I just know that the candidates at
least that we currently have would if
you're lucky give an answer that is even
tangentially related I mean is it you
know that's one of the things where one
of the critiques I've had of the debates
is that the format doesn't really allow
for depth but the other issue is that on
a lot of these issues the candidates
don't really know more than two or three
talking points related to the issue and
that that just seems like more of an I
mean it's just that this is not an area
of expertise really for any of the
candidates I think unless you think
there's someone who is better on this
issue
you know III I think you know obviously
someone like Bernie Sanders has got the
right idea of the scale of funding
involved to make this problem go away
but again it's it's sort of about owning
this as an issue when you read the paper
it's almost as if we are continually
surprised for example that hurricanes
affect poor people and black people for
example worse than white people or
well-off people and you sort of think to
yourself gosh you know what else in
social space do we treat like this it's
as if the hurricane is coming way way
from the from the outside of our
knowledge and it's like short
bad thing effects poor suffering people
worse and it's labeled what doesn't do
that we should be owning this right now
instead of figuring out how to become
more familiar with it otherwise it's
just this huge daunting mountain of data
that we're looking at like freaked out
Romantic poets or something yeah I mean
your book being ecological is not about
beating people over the head with facts
but how would you how would you sort of
summarize the effect you would hope the
book would have on someone who reads it
oh um well I got asked by penguin to
write this book and I thought gosh
penguin you've given me a golden
microphone to talk to people and I'm a
scholar I don't get out much when I go
to talk it's like what do i how can I
use this opportunity right and you know
people like me say you know things we
have this horrible phrase what does it
appeal to a wider audience that's so
condescending you know I personally
think that making a nice thing for lots
of people to read is off a level in a
way from being right in that heavy-duty
medieval way that happens in
universities I'm making a kind of rubber
stamping motion with my hand because
that's how it sort of works whereas you
know on being interesting you know is
that that a philosopher called
Heraclitus is an ancient Greek
philosopher and he saw something very
beautiful I love very much he says the
truth can't be directly stated you have
to evoke it right and all this direct
stating and pointing and this is bad and
you're a bad person it's just not I mean
I'm quite a defiant person so if I hear
this kind of thing coming to myself
attention consistent pretty strongly so
my sense of the project is just
basically trying to very gently evoke
things which ends up becoming more
powerful actually than yelling there's a
very good phrase I heard once about the
novelists Marcel Proust by one of my
favorite philosophers actually a guy
called Theodor Adorno the German
philosopher and he says something very
beautiful which you could also think
about Jane Austen if you've never read
Proust he says sir the priests destroys
the aristocracy with remorseless
gentleness that's the phrase that he
uses and I like this idea of
of gentleness can be more effective than
aggression you think about the
nonviolent direct action things that
have happened Martin Luther King and so
on you sort of see the point of that I'm
going to phrase this last question and
what maybe is not ripe for an academic
answer but if zero is total pessimism
and ten is total optimism about figuring
this out before we destroy ourselves
where are you well two and a half years
for ambiguity because on the one hand as
far as understanding this issue goes I'm
at a 1 or a zero
you know pessimism of the intellect as
they say as far as feeling like we've
got this actually if we can do this it
just takes a little tiny adjustment and
to get into doing this I'm at a nine or
a ten actually so it's very ambiguous
for me pessimism of the intellect
optimism of the will that's why that's
my slogan so the answer is depending on
where are you from zero to ten it the
the the answer is it depends from where
you are measuring in some variants it's
like the zero will turn is that don't
mess with mister in between that's what
I say we've been speaking with Timothy
Morton who's an ecological philosopher
at Rice University the book is being
ecological Timothy so great having you
on today thank you so much has been a
pleasure